today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet
join them at expressvpn.com yang
[Music]
[Applause]
tell the truth you you probably will
lose your seat
you know because not just because the
voters will turn on you but because the
party establishment will turn on you
lose it anyway i know that is a is a
candidate i said things that man lady
you're getting off the stage you're not
going to be on the stage next time but
you know what andrew
maybe i'm i was not they were able to
cut me off at the knees in terms of
funding and
so forth maybe they didn't want me a
little party online at the democratic
convention but you know
what i'm still saying it and in america
today
you should say it so so lose the
election damn it
lose it if it means you lose the
election and i i honestly think
you know there's something about being
my age
and i'm old enough to remember i was a
little girl but i do remember the
assassinations of bobby kennedy and
martin luther king
and a lot of people younger than my
generation
don't necessarily realize the
psychological
effect the chilling effect that it had
on us
that people such as martin such as bobby
who were speaking
truth juice the real thing
you talk about the soul of america they
were literally shot and killed in front
of our eyes
and there was a very loud unspoken
message in those assassinations
and those bullets psychically shot all
of us and just in case we hadn't gotten
the message they shot students at kent
state to make sure we got the message
and the message was go home there will
be no further protest
do whatever you want in the private
sector
but leave the public sector alone to
whomever it is
once it's so bad it's willing to to kill
in order to control it
and that's what my generation did in
large part but you know what has
happened to people who are my age
the idea that as my father would say
the bastards got to you the idea that we
might not
die knowing on the day we die that we
didn't really do what we came here to do
is actually scarier to us than the
thought that they might kill us if we do
to be a radical truth-teller in america
today is to take a risk
and my message is take it anyway
[Music]
andrew we are seven months into
the worst pandemic
we've ever seen or since what's called
the worst global crisis since world war
ii
and there has been every american's
gotten 1200 bucks
so six dollars a day or so you can do
that math better than me
something like that that's it it's
disgusting
yeah it's reprehensible what we've
allowed to have
have happened and uh i'm
thrilled that there's pressure to get
back to the table because this bill
should have been passed months ago we
can all see that
over 80 of americans agree with cash
relief during the pandemic
over half of americans now want
universal basic income in perpetuity
and a bunch of house democrats
many of whom were in competitive races
actually came out with their own plan
um because they wanted to help bridge
this gap between
the heroes act that pelosi is
leading with a three trillion dollar
price tag and then the republicans
signaled that they'd
come up to something like 1.3 uh and
to most humans it's that sounds like a
you could make a deal it's like i'm at
three
they come with one they move up to 1.3
maybe you make some moves too like maybe
you wind up uh
somewhere like two-ish and then see what
happens
and you could do a world of good for
tens of millions of americans with two
trillion dollars
uh aid to states enhanced unemployment
benefits
cash relief and a bunch of moderate
or vulnerable frankly democratic members
of congress
came out and said here's another plan
let's work with that
and that's increasing pressure on nancy
and house leadership as it should
because this is not uh
one party's entirely to blame situation
this is a just get to the [ __ ] table
and make a deal
situation uh this is not a time for
political
point scoring just so many people are
hurting so
i i'm disgusted that we're still having
this conversation in mid-september
uh the last bill was past the end of
march
uh so like you said you're talking about
six
plus months uh without aid and even
after you pass a bill it takes a little
while for the aid to
get out to people um so it's
it's freaking a dysfunctional mess in dc
and it shows that we have to change
things fundamentally
the i think a lot of us are so
entrenched andrew we're like we're
republican or democrat and we think the
other side is
the bad guys and that we're the good
guys and to me looking at this is so
freaking obvious
neither one is a good guy they both are
they both suck right now
they both are not helping you um because
if they were actual good guys in my
opinion they would get
i don't know i feel like if i was in
congress would i bail out
a bunch of companies if i knew i got a
whole bunch of cash for people that were
hurting like would i compromise
that to help people yes if i was a
republican and i wanted to bail out my
company would i let
the people get some money in addition
like just pass
the big one to me like they're both
they're playing political calculus
political ping-pong
wow millions it's the whole country is
just
it's just burning man it's just burning
there's nothing to say but this is super
frustrating and to your point
it's systematic it's not the individual
congress people in general it's just we
the system's broken it's painful no we
we have a system where
you'd rather uh everyone loses than at
the other side seems like they gotta win
because because you have
members of congress that are much more
vulnerable to getting primaried
by their own party or having people turn
against them
then they're going to be rewarded for
compromising and reaching across the
aisle
and this this is something i've been
digging into now
this last number of days and weeks where
the numbers are shocking
zach you have uh an approval rating of
21 for our members of congress
collectively
versus congress collectively and then
they're in congress
and then their re-election rate is 94
over the last number
of cycles because because you
you can't beat an incumbent they start
out with their million dollar moat
uh only a handful of people vote in the
primaries so
let and over 80 percent of seats are
safe so they're either
clean democratically and republican so
let's say you're uh
a republican in one of these seats
you're only worried about someone tea
partying you
more or less because you know if if you
get to the general then
you win in a cakewalk in part thanks to
gerrymandering but in part thanks to
geography
and so the only thing you're worried
about is someone flamethrowing and
coming and saying like
this person uh you know isn't a true
conservative and so you yeah so you'd
rather
do nothing and say um that
you know you stood for quote-unquote
principles because that's actually
better for your job security
and that there's a similar situation
going on for democrats
and then you have have house leadership
that's been
there for 30 plus years uh
and they they're keeping unfortunately
members
uh on a tight leash where they're like
look stay stay
with the party there's very very little
bipartisanship
or people crossing party lines if you
look at the heroes act the three
trillion dollar
relief act that the house passed
only one republican voted for it it was
peter king in long island and he voted
for it and he said cleanly he was like
look new york's getting devastated i'm
just gonna go along with this because
like my district is getting blasted into
smithereens which
you can imagine like that decline
economic activity
that's it no other republican came
forward and said i'm for this thing
except for peter king
and then you had 14 democrats in the
house say that
they weren't going to support it because
they thought that it was
uh going to die in the senate they said
this is not actually a bipartisan
effort this is just going to drive the
republicans in the senate to
kneecap this thing and not even consider
it and uh and they were right
it turns out so if you have 14 democrats
who looked at this and said look
this is never actually going to result
in a
a real relief bill because the
republicans
will won't stand for it and of the 14
democrats that did not support the
heroes act
a lot of them were brand new to congress
uh so they they hadn't gotten frankly
like you know brought into the
party machinery to a point where nancy's
like you know you can't do anything um
like independent of us uh and the second
thing is a lot of them were in swing
states
where they're vulnerable uh so you had
people like abby finkenauer from iowa or
sheriff david from kansas
who are like i'm just not going to go
along with this thing because
uh you know i just don't think it's
going to get republican support and it
turns out that they were right
so so you have a lot of dynamics zach
that are going into the fact that
it's better for uh many people
in leadership to not have a relief bill
passed and to have
something imperfect pass
what we joked when we were running
we'd be like hey we even if we pass
universal basic income
we still got a lot of work to do like
what
so there's a lot of stuff that's like
fundamental is there anything that can
be changed now
like what's like you know what i'm
saying like we talked a lot about not
positive we talked a lot about ranked
choice voting and
getting money out of politics and
adjusting the media so we're not so
polarizing and regulating social media
the right way
so people aren't so divisive and
addicted to these you know ideological
ideas and right and left
but those are longer term solutions that
we are working on in some ways in
humanity forward um
what's the best move now is it get
behind biden and then pre and
put the people that we believe are for a
lot of these reforms in his
administration to pressure them like
what
what's the short-term fix man because i
i need it right now
i need to get on my mental depression
right now it's
call members of congress say we need a
relief bill we need a relief bill
and for the approximately 40 members of
congress who came forward with an
independent plan
support them and say look nancy
get back to the table come down from
uh from your vantage point and
start compromising because
i agree well i i mean we all know that i
think that
uh joe and kamala winning uh and then
having congress hopefully be aligned up
uh
is what we're going to need to take more
dramatic action in
january february march but i want to get
[ __ ] done right now
you know it's like people can't wait
until january february march
so right now it's reaching out to
members of congress uh
and letting them know that inaction is
unacceptable that you're a voter and
organizer and activist
and they need to get to the table
so i saw something there's a little
curveball at you but i know you have
thoughts on it so
i saw two things one joe biden's
team which i i've said a member time
they are pros they are
um probably not inclined to think out of
the box like we did pretty often but
they have they all know what they're
doing in terms of
working in for a presidential campaign
or national scale um
they are putting together um
a very very strong legal team for a
fight in november
um for counting votes
so we don't have a 2000 election um like
we did in florida
they're pushing gore um and trump
tweeted this morning so this uh we're
recording this on
on thursday the 17th we'll be out on the
20th um
or on monday monday um
he tweeted this morning that the
election is gonna take i gotta find the
exact quote but like she's gonna take a
while like this is gonna be
it's not gonna be accurate and do you
think he's setting the stage
to take advantage of this system we're
talking about
you know yeah this is the nightmare
scenario that unfortunately
um is in my mind also the likely
scenario which is that we don't have an
outcome
on the night of november 3rd it drags on
for a while because a lot of votes will
be mailed in
in swing states that will not be able to
be called until more of those votes get
counted
and so the time frame will drag on and
the biden
team is very smart to have lawyers at
the ready to
uh make or anticipate
challenges to the results uh i think
that joe and kamala
if you were just to count every vote
magically
they're in position to win um and i get
the sense that trump actually agrees
with that and that the
main plan on the other side is going to
be to
try and cast doubt on particular
vote counts and results uh and so the
fact that biden teams ready to fight
that
is very positive uh i i
i think that americans are smart and can
sense that this is what's going on
and that that they're going to be uh
be some votes that get counted
after election night and they always
have to be able to trust in the results
when they get reported
yeah he um he's the master tonight he
denies everything um
and sometimes he's accused falsely of
things to be real um
but there's plenty of times where he's
screwed up and he just denies it and the
fact is there's two stories now
you can pick your side and the average
person's like look i don't care
right it's probably maybe it's true
maybe it's not um and so this was the
quote he said the november third
election result
may all caps never be accurately
determined
which to me is terrifying that's where
you have officially said we're not a
democracy anymore
that's that's it to me when the election
gets
[ __ ] with is when you're venezuela is
when you're
you've crumbled well we had the
conversation with nina schick about deep
fakes but
in some ways that era is already upon us
she said that when you can't determine
truth anymore then all that matters is
power
and that's kind of the trump approach is
just like look it's all [ __ ]
uh but you know i'm i'm the person in
power
uh and democrats have been fighting an
uphill battle for
the last four years really saying well
like wait there there's this
uh precedent there's this norm there's
this rule and he's just steamrolling it
all
and you know it shows how fragile our
institutions are
the question is whether our institutions
can stand up to this election
and you know do we have still the
fortitude left and the trust left
uh to believe in vote counts to have
results and then have there be
like a real transition of power uh we're
gonna find out
uh i remain very cautiously optimistic
because i think that you're seeing a lot
of
people who are kind of straddling
both sides or uninvolved actually come
off the sidelines for it
i've always been a believer that cooler
heads will prevail over time
um now 2016 may be an example of that
not taking place but i don't think trump
wasn't as
um as obviously who he is today then
um but also clinton was not um what
biden is
biden is far less polarizing by the
numbers and
by my own personal and our personal
shared experience um
so i do think the silent majority
actually might be with
um like change here um
i don't think that means they all are
going to join the democratic party for
years to come like i think the democrats
got us just as much identities
and soul-searching as the republicans do
um i will say that it's a change
i'll say that i think that the we're
seeing some of the real drawbacks of the
two-party duopoly
uh in effect and there's this quote
that uh um from
this political boss named uh
william tweed in the 19th century he
said
um said i don't care who does the
electing as long as i get to do the
nominating
that's like the interesting
and oh my god and so so this is one of
the things that's infiltrated
in my my thinking on a lot of these
congressional races is like by the time
it gets to folks you really don't have a
meaningful choice a lot of the time
um and if we have different
open primaries with rank choice voting
it's such a game changer like i firmly
believe that if you're looking for
a more effective congress you need to
have
more effective races and election
mechanics
that would actually change the
incentives of the members of congress so
that if they don't compromise
and they come back and say i stuck to my
principles or whatever then you can be
like you know
like [ __ ] you like get out of office
like we put you there to actually do
something and it would be a different
group of voters
because the the number of people who
vote in the primaries it's sub 20
so you have like the um the most extreme
voters on one side or the other who are
deciding that candidates
re-election uh every time and so if you
had a process where it was opened up to
100 of the voters in that district
uh through like an open primary and
ranked choice voting then all of a
sudden it's not enough just to curry
favor with
like 70 percent of your 20 which is
really what's happening right now
it's like as long as i keep 70 of my 20
in line
like that 14 of my district like then my
job is secure uh
and so so if you change that that
reference group to be a hundred percent
then all of a sudden you would see
completely different approaches to
governance
so this was my comment when people want
you to
run for mayor um of new york
yeah this has been my
reaction when people ask you to run for
mayor they're like oh he'd be a
landslide he'd win in a shoe and he
would be a great mayor this kind of
thing
do you realize how many people vote for
the mayor of new york city
it's like 11 of new yorkers 13 of new
yorkers it's
tiny yet everybody has an opinion
hundred percent of new yorkers hate bill
plaza
um but no one votes and so who is
who are those people voting in a mayor's
race and people for
so like the mass mayor's race was in
2017
in june so it's after election year so
no one's thinking politics
um so it happens during because it's a
primary it's always a democrat so the
primaries in june
you the small group people that win are
your die hard dems
your uh the unions right like things
that
like kind of lead to either systematic
like overweight overweighting the system
or frankly corruption
um because you have to just basically
curry favors with either union leaders
or very special interest groups to get
elected
so i think we'd i think you got a shot
to win if you wanted to run
but it's not uh you don't get to vote
you don't get elected by the average
new yorker because then i think you'd
win you got to win the average voter in
a primary
and that's the difference in
presidential politics too it's iowa same
thing we had to get five percent
you know five percent iowans vote that's
not the state that's five percent of
them like that's a
die-hard debt it was it was interesting
man i always used to say on the campaign
trail we just need 40 000 iowans to get
on board to abolish poverty uh and we
got
between nine and ten thousand which in a
way it's like well it's not
that terrible you got like 25 percent of
what you needed to abolish poverty
uh but i always knew it was a very very
confined
uh battleground really it's like like
there's all the noise and the
press and then it's like all i need is
40 000 iowans like let's do this thing
um so these so these elections are
not quite what a lot of people think
they are
um in large part because of our process
and
that this is something that i'd really
love to change
actually it's not i'd love to change we
need to change it if we're going to have
uh functional legislative bodies
functional incentives for our lawmakers
because one of the things i think people
who listen to yang speaks now is that
andrew yang is passionate about
the fact that people will do uh what the
incentives are to do
you know you know you know i mean yeah
you're actually well it's just it's a
lot it's like it's just the way most of
us operate it's like if
if i work as a ceo of a company and it's
like hey are you a good entrepreneur man
it's like hey if you fire everyone and
replace them with automation then you
get paid more money it's like you're
probably gonna do that you know it's
like oh by the way if you don't do that
they're going to fire you
you're probably going to do that if
you're a politician it's like hey if you
curry favor with the most extreme 14
um of the people in your district then
you are secure and if you compromise
then you're screwed
it's like you're probably going to not
compromise
you know like that that's and we're
seeing it play out to disastrous results
right in front of our eyes
so we it's really an incentive change
and the other thing that
is going to be part of changes in my
opinion is term limits it's like we have
this ridiculous
system right now where people can never
get rid of you and you can stay in
congress for 20 30 years and you need to
stay in congress
for 20 plus years to have any real power
because it's like a seniority system
uh where you just have to climb that
totem pole and
and tell me that you can spend 20 years
in dc
and be the same person you were when you
showed up there 20 years prior of course
not like
you become like a completely different
person and all the stuff that only makes
sense
within the context of the institution
of congress or within dc politics but
you know
over time that becomes your language
because you've been there for 20 years
uh
and the thing that blew my mind when i
was looking into this zack is that
something like 88 percent of americans
are four terminals for members of
congress
and 20 states were actually passing term
limits
for their representatives independently
they just said
you know what we think it'd be a good
idea if people just had
like had to come home after a certain
period of time because going to dc
forever is not
great i mean like it's common sense we
all can can sense it
uh and so 20 plus states made rules
about it and then there was a supreme
court ruling
in the mid 90s that said hey this is not
a state matter like you cannot determine
term limits for your own representatives
uh which is ridiculous to me but
it just goes to show that there was like
actually a groundswell movement where
people
in states around the country were like i
preferred if my representative
actually like came back after a
particular period of time we sent
someone new
when was this this was the early 90s
so we've been we've been [ __ ] this up
for 30 years and
but but if you go to the american people
literally like 87 88 percent of people
agree with the
the statement it's like yeah we should
have term limits for members of congress
or
you know going to dc for too long so so
this is something that
needs to happen and the way that i'm
going to pitch it so that it has a
realistic chance of passing
is to say that current lawmakers are
exempt uh
so that look if you've been there
climbing the ranks for 20 years like
you can just stay there until like until
you expire
but the people after you have a term
limit
and then we have a chance of passing it
and you know generation from now
um you know we could have a very
different looking legislature but the
fact is we don't have a generation to
wait like we have to get the stuff done
immediately
uh and and that's uh that's the
frustration that's the need
um i'm with you i think here's what i
will say
i think whatever office we run for again
if we ever do
this is the crux of it it's it's bigger
than ubi which we fought for it's bigger
than automation
even now zach i think about this a lot
where you have ubi
a majority of americans are now for ubi
so ubi will get past tomorrow right
no it's like we can all sense what's
going on now where like
at this point even if a majority of us
are for something a majority of us are
for trying to address climate change
like have we done
anything about that not really so there
are a lot of things that
that we can be for and it doesn't matter
and so to me now one of the major tasks
is trying to make our government
actually responsive to us
uh so being the problem solving type i'm
now digging into the guts of why it does
not seem like
congress listens to us and again the
numbers 21
approval rating 94 re-election rate i
mean like
is that the recipe for behavior change
no
nope um the takeaway here is
vote and if you live in a swing street
state or if you live in any state
particularly if you live in
north carolina is every podcast if you
live in michigan ohio wisconsin
pennsylvania north carolina florida
texas uh and florida bring five friends
bring five friends and texas apparently
up for grabs so holy [ __ ] i mean if we
win tech if joe biden wins texas you can
throw some more plays in there too man
nevada new hampshire
list goes on and on there's a lot of
swing states this time
yeah it's exciting um so bring five
friends especially you all know a friend
that never is gonna [ __ ] vote
or never gonna do anything or doesn't
care about politics you're like trust me
on this
you i'm going to say this andrew this
was my favorite
this was my favorite yankee wow that's
such high praise wow
and at some point but you and her
see things differently and not
necessarily bad or good it's just
different but you
um believe um
[Music]
that our system is corrupting our people
and you believe in the good in people
and you um
not that marion doesn't but you believe
in this altruism of
uh it's kind of this this grace and
forgiveness aspect of how you've managed
how you've led how you've been
entrepreneur and i've
i've experienced as you being my manager
and boss but also
the way you've treated people on the
trail and the way you wouldn't attack
people on personal levels or
um never went nasty when we were running
um
marianne believes a lot of this is like
evil and corruption
and that the the people are in in these
spots are evil and you guys butt heads
on this
a lot um because she's i mean she's a
bulldog in in her own way which is
awesome so i loved the
the back and forth man um and you both
like held your ground in healthy ways
um and your your tendencies kind of came
out in this conversation
what did what did you like about this um
i mean i know you love marianne you guys
have a good relationship i love it
anytime i get to talk to marianne
because
i learned something she's a very
enlightened
uh and brilliant thinker
and uh she sees things that i don't she
sees things that most of us don't
she she sees things that i think america
needed to see
more of uh and so i i just enjoyed the
opportunity to sit down and talk to her
and i think she and i agree on
much much more than we did we disagree
on
um yeah so and i also i think people
know this like i i think
uh she got shafted by the media in a way
that was deeply unfair
uh and i could relate to aspects of that
because i was out on the trail
alongside marianne in various ways and
uh yeah like you know if you actually
listen to what she was saying
like you know it's spot on in most every
respect
uh and she just didn't get a fair shake
yeah you got me you guys agree with i
didn't mean to say this is like a nasty
combo you guys agree with a lot you're
um
trying to solve the same problems
sometimes in different ways i i just
loved it because she's not afraid to be
like andrew i think you're wrong on this
and you're like oh oh all right uh okay
agree to disagree i think it was fun um
and interesting um and you were and you
pushed back as well so um
tune in the one and only well she's an
author she's a
spiritual advisor to oprah she's
something like
she's doing she's written over a dozen
books
um this is a real powerhouse thinker
philosopher presidential candidate that
i got to know quite well on the trail
marianne williamson
this is a really tough time for small
businesses everywhere
and as someone who's run a small
business zach's run a business too
one of the toughest things is trying to
find people quickly
promptly reliably to help do whatever
you need to get done
and indeed.com is the number one job
site in the world
a lot of these markets function in a way
that
eventually one of the markets gets the
most critical mass
and in this space it's indeed.com
where it's at this point the go-to
destination for both
employers and folks who are looking for
a job
you know we used it on the campaign
indeed.com
is the go-to place yeah i've used it a
lot
personally
frankly it's just simple and you only
pay what you need right
you can pause any time or uh and restart
anytime so
right now indeed is offering our yank
speaks listeners a free 75
credit to boost your job post which
means you get the quality candidates
that see it fast
um so try it indeed with a free 75
credit at indeed.com
yang this is the best offer available
anywhere
for this type of service so go right now
to indeed.com
yang terms and conditions apply offer
valid through september 30th
[Music]
i am thrilled thrilled to welcome to
yang speaks
one of the people i was so
excited to connect with on the trail a
fellow presidential candidate
spiritual guide to millions miss
marianne williamson mary ann welcome to
yank speech it's so great to see you
thank you andrew it's always great to
see you yes
uh so you and i have been
uh through a lot together i guess we
could use this as
an opportunity for some collegial
therapy about
the presidential campaign and then our
time
afterwards uh but you and i bonded over
the fact that it seems like the media
was
more interested in presenting some
figment of their imagination the
that the actual individuals that that we
were
um and certainly i felt like that was
true in your case where
you had this breakout debate performance
on one of the the first two debates you
were one of those google people
for everyone uh everyone was really
excited about you and they saw what i'd
seen already which is that you were
speaking the truth and connecting with
folks in a really important way
and then it was almost like uh like this
strange uh shark attack where it seemed
like everywhere you looked
there was some kind of negative media
treatment like it's like oh no no
like you can't be excited about this
person uh and that that was the way it
seemed
from my perspective but certainly from
your perspective
i'm sure it was much more visceral
well it didn't just seem that way it was
that way
clearly someone said get that woman off
the stage
that was very clear and i saw it in some
of their eyes backstage after the debate
when we were in the spin room
i saw some people whose eyes said lady
you're dead you will not be coming back
but i underestimated the
viciousness the the strategy the obvious
talking points she's dangerous she's
crazy
she's she's uh anti-science she's
anti-vac she's
you think i was well whatever and so
yeah it came it was ubiquitous wasn't it
that i
had told age patients not to take their
medicine which
was particularly ridiculous given my
history with aid patients and the fact
that at that time there was no medicine
i mean the most vile and vicious things
actually
um and i thought in terms of you
it was particularly interesting because
i thought that the misogyny was very
clear
you did things andrew that i thought
were adorable like when you put
whipped cream in your volunteers mouths
and when you crowd surfed and you know
all that
if i had done those things so
yeah it was uh quite something
well certainly you can't live in america
and not
know that gender plays an enormous role
uh in treatment of really
anyone but political and presidential
candidates at a much higher level
and i agree with you that some of the
things that
happened on my campaign would have
seemed very very different uh
if if it had come from another candidate
and also you didn't have any previous
political experience
so why did they make that such a big
deal in my case but not in yours
so well they made it a big deal in my
case too
yeah not the same way you know it's not
the same way
you were no well i mean the immediate
treatment of the two of us
was different for sure uh and
like the the caricatures they painted
were different and and that it was
painful
for me uh watching what
people were writing about you given that
you and i had connected so like i knew
you for months before
these the these debates occurred uh
and if you speak to someone individually
you can tell that they're thoughtful
patriotic uh sincere
and then when you see various things
being written about them you're like
well where the heck did that come from
and i agree with you like i'd
underestimated the
uh the capacity of the media to
write a story that suited their needs
rather than something that they were
actually interacting with in
in real life yeah and the lack of
journalistic ethics the using anonymous
tweets as a
source a lie or false narrative is
repeated and then they just repeat it
again and repeat it again
the interesting thing and the sad thing
for me was that when i actually spoke to
audiences
people knew who i was but what that
smear did was convinced
so many people that they didn't want to
come hear me
but i don't leave the experience
just with those memories i leave the
experience with
very inspiring and motivating and um
encouraging and loving memories because
as you know
because you were there doing the same
thing the people that we were talking to
the voters were fantastic now there's
the voters and then there's the
political media industrial complex
uh you fared better by the media uh
political
uh machine than i did but we had the
same experience of the voters
and it was wonderful and
that that gap between those two
i find tragic because what you
represented what i represented what
bernie represented in our own different
ways
was a different conversation a new
conversation one that did not adhere
to the same old same old formulations
and what i experienced is
you did too is that the people are ready
for that the problem is not with the
decency the dignity
or even the regenerative interest of the
american people
and that's where our democracy is broken
and i hope uh
as the months and years unfold
that that rupture can be healed
wherever i went people loved you and i
had the same experience that you did
where
when you have conversations with actual
voters
or families just trying to to improve
their lives
it was essentially a completely
different conversation yes
than what was being had uh in the media
and that connection was
for me profound i think you had more
experience having that connection with
with people than i
because you've been um
a spiritual leader for so long for me
frankly it was like completely new where
uh like i said to in another
interview i was surprised anytime anyone
was excited to see me
because because well you know i was new
to public life
your stump speech was you know this
whole conversa of course i read your
book early in the campaign
which i thought was a wonderful book and
became totally convinced i had no
problem with that whatsoever i had
always been aware
that milton friedman himself had said
that the only way trickle-down economics
would work he said was with the
universal basic income
so i was already somewhat exposed to the
idea
but having read your book um certainly
was on board with that and then in your
stump speech
the whole technology conversation i
think people know
that the fact that that is so left out i
mean we all remember when oren hat
said to mark zuckerberg how do you make
money i mean
right and uh i think we could all feel
that your conversation around technology
was something that we absolutely must be
having in this country
well it feels like the substance of your
campaign
has continued to to progress and grow
i feel like joe said something that
people somewhat attributed to you during
the dnc did you see this where he said
uh
like it's darkness versus light and
we're going to bring the light
yeah and i i wrote a book in the
1998 called healing the soul of america
so it's a concept
i'm pretty familiar with however
interestingly enough
when i wrote that book i didn't just say
heal the soul of america i actually
talked about the policies
that were necessary in order to realign
the soul of america with with people's
lives
so everything that they said i was but i
wasn't
uh is almost what i feel this healing
this all of america campaign on joe's
uh behalf is like talk to me policy talk
to me policy talk to me policy
pretty ironic i think well when we were
stumping around
the early states you know joe was making
the same case like that is a battle for
the soul of america
and you presented it in different terms
i feel like so many people were drawn to
you because uh your
diagnosis of what has gone wrong i think
we all can see it's that that there is
there is something more than just this
one malignant narcissist who happens to
occupy the white house right now
absolutely there's
there's this entire almost disease
uh and your prescription was spiritual
renewal
you said look like you can't beat the
disease with uh
with bullet points uh or you can't beat
the disease with
you so it it was it that the two things
were tied together i feel like where
number one is uh the need for profound
renewal and then number two a
prescription that actually
takes concrete forms and and improves
people's lives
well the concrete forms are extremely
important
because when you say spiritual renewal
spirituality is simply the path of the
heart
an economic system that places uh
profitability short-term profitability
for huge multinational corporate
entities
before any moral or ethical concern or
responsibility to people or to plan it
that's a political issue it's an
economic issue that reflects
heartlessness and that has been going on
for 40 years
that trickle down economics is based on
that idea that the only responsibility
of the corporation
should be fiduciary towards stockholders
at the
expense of other stakeholders like
workers or planet or community or
environment
so that that that that is a disease it's
not like a disease it's a moral
disease and interestingly enough like i
said before even
milton friedman who mainly articulated
that said this will only work
if you have a universal basic income and
of course they left that part
out so it's a spiritual
malfunction but i never on the campaign
nor do i now
disconnect that from the economic and
political and social issues
which reflect that heartlessness which
has caught which have caused some
unbelievable unnecessary suffering for
millions of people tens of millions of
people here in the united states and
elsewhere
we don't have health insurance because
of health insurance companies and
big pharma that's why we don't have you
know why we don't have medicare for all
we have a foreign policy that is driven
more so
more by short-term profits for defense
contractors because the
military-industrial complex has more
uh power than the state department we
give 760 billion to the defense
department
40 billion to the state department so i
don't think the conversation is
is is is puffy it's not woo
in fact i think the conversation they're
having on the campaign now is
from my taste i think we need to be
talking about the political changes and
the economic changes that absolutely
have to occur
in order to heal this country well one
thing that i found
so heartening marianne is that you and i
agreed i think on the vast majority of
policy
and we arrived at it from different
angles where i i had this sort of
technology lens where i was like oh this
is really not going to work very well
it's just going to work worse and worse
as technology takes off
and you came at it from a values lens
but arrived at a lot of the same places
yeah you know and i was thrilled that
that you uh championed universal basic
income
uh before the pandemic hit and now it
seems like everyone's on board with
universal basic income or version
thereof
but you saw it during the campaign yeah
i did uh and
and many of the things that that you
described i completely agree with where
you you described our healthcare system
is like look this is not actually
a system to make us healthy like this is
a system of profit
and revenue and that we we need to have
a completely different approach if
you're going to try and actually make us
stronger and healthier
uh there were so many things you said
that i think people
agree with and i think that one of the
marks of your campaign is that a lot of
your ideas
are continuing to grow in residence
and the pandemic has unfortunately for
everyone laid bare a lot of the
nonsense where like people were arguing
about healthcare delivery and now it's
like well
shoot like you know if you have a
pandemic you kind of need some kind of
universal healthcare system if
you're going to be able to help people
or or fight the pandemic
for a basic income now it's well shoot
there are millions of people that don't
have jobs through no fault of their own
and we need to deliver
economic resources to them we had 40
of americans even before the pandemic
who could not be able to absorb
a 400 unexpected expenditure we had 93
million people even before the pandemic
who were living near poverty
we had uh we had hundreds of thousands
of people who were homeless we had
millions of people
living with chronic economic despair so
you came out of in a place that that's
not workable
i came at it from a place of that's
unbelievable
accumulation of economic tension and
anxiety and despair
which is never workable it is outrageous
so the same heartless immoral economic
ethos that
dominated our political system before
the pandemic
is now just on steroids i mean this the
fact that
that mitch mcconnell yesterday they
finally come out with a plan it is
almost a slap in the face
it is almost i'd call it the drop dead
plan
and how people the american people have
been so trained for so long to expect
so little yeah but they're showing their
rage
had our expectations uh lowered
and lowered and lowered and so many
people propagandized to believe
that somehow it's for their own good
that they have to struggle the way they
do
i love during the republican convention
when mike pence was saying all these
wonderful things about this woman
and uh and she was a wonderful woman i
think her son was
i can't remember but something and he
said she's so wonderful and she works
three jobs
and i thought to myself you're proud of
that
we should not be celebrating the need to
work three jobs
that's not a sign of virtue uh or
anything that we should be
celebrating yeah
it's a sign that we're all um on this
hamster wheel and that sometimes not
even one hamster wheel will do the trick
like you need to
get on three simultaneously in order to
make ends meet uh in a lot of parts of
the country
uh so did did you watch the i i watched
both the dnc and the rnc i thought you
were great by the way
i thought you were wonderful um yes i
watched all of the democratic and all of
the republican
me too and uh you know like it was
it was a fascinating parallel universe
like i felt myself dropped into with uh
really to some extent both of them
honestly um but
uh but i recognized more of one than the
other uh
and the and the rnc i joked
uh that it it felt like uh like the
movie starship troopers to me i don't
know if you remember that movie
no but i saw you tweet about it and i
looked it up
yeah i is a satire but authoritarianism
is what the movie was
well i didn't think it was satire at all
it was the very real thing
i thought that the republican convention
was evil genius
i thought it was brilliant in its
maleficent maleficent maleficent
yeah it was malevolent in a brilliant
way um
i the way they took genuine moments
genuine human authenticity and they
wrapped it around
big lies uh
i i i thought it was brilliant in a very
evil way
and also the thing that i felt was the
saddest as someone who wants
joe biden to win very badly
they prosecuted a case against joe biden
why didn't the democratic convention
prosecute a case against donald trump
if ever there was a prosecutable
criminal in the white house
here it is they didn't prosecute a case
kamala harris is a famous prosecutor why
didn't you prosecute a case and the
other thing is
the republican party even though the
vast majority of it was
lies bragged about policies we did this
most of the time it was a lie we're
going to do that most of the time it's
probably a lie the democratic convention
where was the policy so i
hope that something was learned by the
strategists
in the biden campaign
and i hope they come out swinging much
harder
in the weeks that we have left
you say about the rnc
it's true that they would take real
human stories
human sentiment individuals and then
they would
wrap them in this other set of ideas or
values or
propositions and you would see it and
the the wild thing even for me where i'd
be like well that part of it
i appreciate and value and agree with
but they've taken it someplace
else that you know i don't agree with or
appreciate our value at all
and that was like a repetitive theme but
you're right it was very well done
it was so they will take some story
that is so touching and so real that if
you didn't know the facts if you didn't
know the larger context you think wow
these people really care
it was like a purse thief saying look
over there look over there
so they had you look over here so they
weren't looking over there
where what was really happening and that
had to do with race it had to do with
the economy
it had to do with everything um
they're playing a very tough game uh
one of the things i said repeatedly on
the campaign trail was that the only way
to beat
outrageous lies is with some outrageous
truth
and i hope we're going to see some more
hard-hitting
outrageous truths um over the next few
weeks for the democrats now
on the campaign trail there were to be
honest
only three of us really laying down some
out registers and that was you and me
and bernie
and tulsi to some extent so
i hope a more radical level of truth
telling
will be adopted over over the next few
weeks
[Music]
there was a ted talk a little while ago
about how the content we consume is a
little bit like food
you know where you you can you know what
junk food is
for your parade the question is what
what is
good food well what is like the content
that actually will elevate you
that will make you feel like you have a
better sense of the world
the the new yorker to me is one of the
paragons of quality content providing
they really commit
to journalism that gives you a better
understanding of the world
i've been a fan of theirs for a long
time uh and
we all know their caption like the
cartoons and whatnot
uh that you know i got to participate in
a new yorker caption contest
and it felt like i was part of a
literary history a little bit
you know it was like an elevating
experience so the new yorker has a
special deal
for subscribers of yang speaks that
knocked my socks off
you can get 12 weeks of the new yorker
for just six dollars
that's a savings of 50 percent plus
listeners to my show
will receive an exclusive tote bag free
wow
a new yorker tote bag that'd be classy
go to new yorker.com
yang that's n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r-dot-com
yang to get 12 weeks of the new yorker
for just six dollars in a free tote bag
newyorker.com yang i'll say this
on the trail the new yorker wrote really
great pieces about us i always thought
were fair
one in particular emily witt wrote a
piece in july of 2019 right as we were
getting
heating up and he said how andrew yang's
robot apocalypse can heal a divided
nation and it was a fascinating piece
so again for a limited time you get 12
weeks in new york yorker just six bucks
at savings of 50 plus listeners to yank
speaks get it the exclusive tote bag so
new yorker.com
yang that's n-e-w-y-o-r-k-e-r dot com
slash yang to get 12 weeks in new yorker
for just
six bucks and a free tote bag
newyorker.com
yang
[Music]
you have helped turn me on to several
progressive congressional candidates
around the country i've been supporting
some of these candidates too
uh and i'm incredibly grateful to you
for
both supporting some of them and also
saying hey you should check this
candidate out
uh and it's been a lot of fun for me i
i've
sensed that you share it too because
these congressional candidates
are so incredible and awesome and like
they have the right ideas and values and
policies
and they're not really getting a whole
lot of visibility or support in many
contexts
it has kind of blown my mind how
little in the way of national resources
is going to
many down ballot candidates around the
country in districts that
maybe they're not a slam dunk for
democrats but they should at least be
competitive
and uh and it feels like you and i are
some of the only people supporting at
least some of these
these candidates where you and i differ
though is that you
have an attitude of wow it really blows
my mind
i have an attitude of how [ __ ] dare
they because there's a reason for what
you just said and that is the corporate
democratic machinery
that does as much to purge
progressive voices on a congressional
level and a senatorial level
as they do on a presidential level just
like they did with the presidential race
this time and they did with the
presidential race
last time in the democratic primaries
and so
the progressive candidates and i agree
with you there's some great people
many of whom did not make it through
their primaries many some of whom did
but they are not given the support they
often are not the people who already
have their own
resources they're not lawyers and
business people necessarily
they might be scientists they might be
teachers or whatever
and the the money from the democratic
party
is given to those that are what they
believe are the candidates
um uh who are more likely to win this is
why our friend john hickenlooper who i
certainly he was a lovely man but this
is why we have john who is didn't even
want to run
we have him rather than the
extraordinary andrew romanoff in
colorado
it's why we had sarah gideon rather than
than betsy sweet it's why we have um
amy mcgrath instead of breyer or booker
so
it's there's something dark there you
know and it
i believe it needs to be named and i
believe that it's the wrong call for the
democratic party
i don't think that's where the people of
the united states are and it's certainly
not
where the majority of democrats are the
majority of people in this country
andrew want medicare for all
when you look at things such as
cancellation of college loan debt
when you look at things like universal
health care when you look at things like
uh free college tuition at state
colleges and universities
these are very popular ideas
so why are we running a presidential
campaign where apparently
there's more effort to to lure
republicans than there is to please so
many democrats particularly progressive
democrats
i don't understand it i don't understand
why there were more young people
at the at the convention speaking i
don't know why there's not more reaching
out
i don't know why the burden is only on
them to
fall in line some of whom i'm very
frustrated with as well don't get me
wrong
because i do believe that the most
important thing is to remove the
fascists from the white house
but i also see on the part of the
democratic party a pushing away
of people who are voters or the very
least potential voters
and that concerns me very much it didn't
work in 16
and if they're not careful it won't work
in 2020
i'm with you on the frustration and one
of the things that i saw
work out in the primaries is that if you
were progressive running against an
incumbent there were very very few
organizations or figures who will help
you
uh and that's true even if let's say you
were
let's say you're a member of congress
and you're like a died in the world
progressive
it's very very unseemly for you to
endorse
someone who's primary one of your
current colleagues like that there there
were some real rules against that
in terms of decorum and so if you are
let's call it a progressive democrat
running against an incumbent
like that there like it it staggered me
how short the list is of folks who might
conceivably get behind you because
democratic establishment is not going to
get behind you unless the incumbent
is mired in scandal it's more than a
supercharger it's more than about
incumbency
it's about more than incumbency it's
about a viewpoint of the corporate
centrist democrat
it's not just the incumbency and when it
comes to the incumbency issue
there have been some real wins look at
cory bush she was able to defeat
a longtime incumbent look at jamal
bowman who was able to defeat the
long-time
uh incumbent and of course that whole
trend was started with aoc
who defeated the long-term incumbent um
so bush in particular the race is on
yeah corey bush in particular because it
was in in missouri
uh and her opponent i think his name was
lacey clay
um uh like hadn't
screwed up in like any any uh mammoth
fashion i mean i was excited for cory's
victory
um but in missouri you could see it more
clearly in a place like aoc's district
or jamal bowman's district
um but missouri was an earthquake uh
the problem is that it is so remarkable
frankly that you're like no way like an
incumbent lost
to their primary challenger i looked
this up marianne because you know i love
math
uh the incumbent reelection rate is 94
percent
so if you are going to to defeat an
incumbent you're
you're literally at least statistically
looking at you know like a sub 10
chance uh of victory and now having seen
the dynamics play on these races i
understand
that more clearly because no one wants
to help you
you know except for frankly someone like
you someone like me sometimes
like a very very small handful of
organizations because
people are loath to antagonize the
incumbent
and getting behind the upstart seems
like a bad move quote unquote
politically
even if you know that that person's in
better
step with the values of that district or
with the american people
so the problems are i mean the problems
are manifold like i'm actually starting
now to get a clearer sense of just how
screwed up
the systems are in terms of i hope you
are what you do
about the the majority will it's like
there are a lot of things that the
majority of americans agree on now and
then
so you have the american people then you
have the corporate interests then you
have the legislators
uh and at this point it's almost
it's not quite irrelevant but it's
almost irrelevant if the majority of the
people are for it well exactly
and it's and it's totally absurd and
naive for us to even pretend
that the political parties are uh seeing
as their first job facilitating the
voices of the people
they do more to manipulate and to
dictate uh
than to facilitate look at something
like what's happening right now with
black lives matter
black lives matter is the largest social
movement that has ever existed in the
united states
and how much of a difference has it made
in any legislation whatsoever
the voices of the people this is what's
wrong the democracy itself is broken
and as far as the incumbency is
concerned it's a club
and the club has many ways of protecting
itself and multi
layers of resistance to any penetration
into any change
and this is a a
i think this might even be a place where
you and i see things differently
because i don't believe that an
incremental boring from within
uh is quite enough i think we need a
more fundamental disruption
um that will take a more moment oh i'm
with you don't worry i do not disagree
one bit
i read your tweets i read some tweet
where you said
the good thing about that is joe will go
for it and then he'll bring
all the center with him i'm
i you know i'm optimistic and yeah
yeah on joe's appetite for
going being on some of these relief
efforts but if you ask me hey
incremental versus fundamental i'm
fundamental all the way and
that and the thing that you you and i
represented when you talk about the club
i feel like you and i
get along in part because we tried to
crash the party
yeah but wait a minute wait a minute
wait wait let's be very clear
you made it you were invited by the cool
kids you were invited in
so you get to sit with the cool kids now
now i
am happy for you that you get to sit
with the cool kids but i don't think
there should be a cool kid's table in
america
not an american either well at the table
andrew
my goal would be to get to that table to
the extent i ever do become a cool kid
which for the you know
you've been invited in andrew you've
been invited in let's not pretend here
okay and but and then your goal is what
to do with what with that
to make the table enormous enough where
like the everyday american actually
feels like they can just come up and
take a seat and it's comfortable and
it's not like this crazy
pyramid where like you have to be at
like the pinnacle to feel like you
matter you know like that that to me is
the fundamental truth right now in
american life is that
our system does not care about the
everyday
uh shopkeeper truck driver retail worker
or whatnot unless you happen to have a
million dollar stash that you're gonna
throw with that like that so
let me ask you a question so you
are as passionate as i am and as
passionate as millions of others
about direct cash relief yes you're
talking about all the time
well have you noticed have you noticed
that the democrats aren't suggesting it
so at what point do you think
when you say your goal is to change it
at what point is it going to change
and at what point at what point does
someone
who doesn't color between the lines
that's the difference between you and me
we agree but i have a bigger mouth than
you do i'm a big
i'm not as careful as you i just say it
maybe because i'm older maybe because
i'm jewish i don't know why and so
i don't know where you get at what point
at what point do you think
i i feel that their that their
resistance
to um anything that messes with the
basic power structure
is more um fierce
than you do because your experience is
different than mine
they let you in and i saw what they did
to someone who was more
vocal about what was happening
so i i believe that there's a room for
both there's
places for everybody to do it as they
feel needs to do it
i don't think you're more optimistic
about america but i think you're more
optimistic about
the um willingness of the system to
self-correct
the system as it now exists quite
possibly though now
i'm a hundred percent
sure that we need to actually fix the
machinery of democracy
in order for it to represent the will of
the people anymore
okay so in part because of what you just
described about cash relief
uh to me it's obscene that you don't
have every single democrat on board with
a version of cash relief instead of the
50 or so that currently are on board
thank you
it shouldn't it didn't include jokes
shouldn't it include joe biden
yeah she should include joe and karma
should that's my point to you
that's my point
so what we've done is we've actually
tried to put pressure on
individual members of congress say why
aren't you for this bill why aren't you
for this bill
and we've managed to get a few more not
as not as many as i'd want because to me
so apparently one of the magic numbers
to try and hit interest is after you get
100 legislators on board
then uh then it starts taking on like
oh my gosh like this thing may pass what
are the reasons
what are they going to hunt essentially
democrats and say look get on this bill
get on this bill
and then get it to a point where it
becomes the relief measure
hopefully what are the reasons or
excuses that people democrats have given
you for why they're not
well i'm like you in that i think many
of these members of congress are just
going to do whatever they think is in
their
political self-interest so if you say to
me why are they not on this bill
it's because they think it's better for
their political self-interest not to be
on the bill
so then you say well how do you make it
so that it's in your political
self-interest to be on the bill
and one one way to do it for me is for
me to say
hey look the yang gang would like you a
lot more if you are on this bill oh
and if you're not on this bill then
maybe we will support this person who's
going to challenge you
and so so those are the kinds of
conversations that we have actually
been having and they haven't been as
successful
as we'd like because people right now do
not see
that it's in their political
self-interest to do what the american
people see is obvious
because right now 75 percent of us think
that there should be cash relief during
the pandemic so once again why is it
that
you don't just do what everyone knows is
common sense and the right thing to do
i don't know why you think it would make
you unpopular to say
to people we're sending you money so you
can survive
exactly like how is this not a home run
for you
and the same with medicare for all
though the same with so many of these
issues so to me
i mean there are so many problems uh
stacked in here uh the main problem is
that
if you are a member of congress with a
94 success rate
at being re-elected you just become this
creature of
uh of washington um and you have these
consultants around you whose careers
depend upon
your continued uh membership in congress
and so if someone comes and says hey
like do this big thing
um that will to at least some people in
your district make you seem
um like quote unquote like radical or
something about those lines
they have like five people who are
essentially like their brakes on any
kind of move like that being like no no
no like uh like
don't don't embrace this thing they're
they're like they're barnacles on them
uh and the goal has to be that we
actually make it so that
they see that the water is fine and that
if they go this direction it will help
them
see that's where you and i are that's
where you and i separate a little bit
it's called corruption total
and complete corruption it's not only
what you said about their constituents
it's also about the leadership of the
party
when nancy says we're doing this no
we're not doing that
and even the ones who would agree with
us and are playing the long game so they
go along
that's exactly what i mean now
until that's called uh for what it is
and when you talk about all of the
operatives yeah they're they're circus
performers it's it's uh
that's why i call it a campaign
industrial complex it's
thicker darker and deeper than
i feel we just we're describing in this
conversation
and it has nothing to do with a
government of buying for the people
it's a government of by and for the
corporate interests
that are then spending all the money in
order to
make sure some people win and some other
people lose it's not just
the uh the the consultants it's what the
consultants are telling them
and so you know i don't know why
in congress unlike in every other
profession we all have to make ethical
decisions
you've you've been in business you've
you have a career where i'm sure you
were called upon to make an ethical
decision i might make more money if i
make the unethical decision
but i'm a human being who wants to
respect myself so i'm going to make the
ethical decision
i don't know why we give congress people
a pass
oh well he or she can't vote the right
way because they'd lose their job
lose your seat have some
have some conscience lose your seat if
it means if doing the right thing means
you lose your seat
lose your seat and we need to say that
and we need to call them on that and we
need to get over our delusion
that if we just vote blue
it'll all be fixed i mean if you look at
the bailout if you look at the
this bailout which is so horrifying the
as i said
i call it the drop dead bailout it's
corporate bailout as opposed to people
bailout right and i know you feel
strongly about this
yeah it's it's really the same template
as the bailout in 2008.
the bailout in 2008 was corporations
versus people
and they just took the same template and
they went on steroids
the whole system is that corrupt and yet
the system mitigates against people
calling it out on its corruption and
that and that's why it's going to be an
awakening of the american people
who vote uh in such in in such massive
numbers for people who
are calling it and what we have are so
many people who recognize the corruption
but who feel that their way of resisting
is by not voting
which i can't i i can't judge
because i understand the psychological
yes you can't judge because
to ask them to pay attention to this zoo
is just bad for their mental health is
that bad for their frame of mind
you know it'll like make them angry and
uh despair written more than it's going
to invigorate them
um so that's the tough part is that it's
rational for a lot of people to check
out because of just how bad it is i
wouldn't call it rational
but it's understandable yeah
understandable you have to give people
something to vote for
that's the thing direct cash relief
would be something people would vote for
medicare for all is only people would
vote for college
you know cancellation of college loans
do you know how many people would show
up to vote for a presidential candidate
who said i'm going to make your life
easier
and i'm sorry it's not enough to just
say oh
yield is all of america how about some
policies is going to make your life
easier
it's not enough to just say we're not
donald trump
[Music]
here at yang speaks you know we think
that our data should be ours
and right now your internet service
provider can see every site you've ever
visited even if you use
incognito mode incognito mode really
does not work
as well as you think nor does clearing
your history
at this point you can have your data
sold and resold legally
to ad companies now how do we improve on
the situation
expressvpn reroutes and encrypts your
internet connection through their
servers so it's like
you're beaming in from a whole other
place and no one can
identify anything you did if that sounds
appealing to you
then sign up for expressvpn and go to
expressvpn.com
yang to get three months free on a one
year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang expressvpn.com yang it's the number
one rated vpn by cnet and wired
companies use it and if you are
interested in securing your data
this is the service for you so stop
being weird stop using incognito mode
download expressvpn expressvpn.com
yang get your three months free and
start protecting your privacy
one big structural change that i think
might help activate members of congress
to try and get something done and then
come home uh would be term limits
where you say look you have a certain
period of time of service
in our nation's capital and then you're
coming home so
now you don't need to worry so much
about trying to stake out your
multi-decade path to the committee ship
or whatnot like
you could actually just make
determinations based upon what you think
the people you are excited about would
like and you have this term of service
and then you come home
i have two minds about that on one hand
elections should be term limits that's
what elections should be
abraham lincoln said there's not that
much evil that any
uh one government can do in this country
as long as the people remain vigilant
what we have is the problem of
gerrymandering and so forth of course
which hr one
that the house passed would would fix
and if we get the house
if the democrats get the house and the
senate that structural reform might
exist uh
might uh happen in terms of getting rid
of gerrymandering etc
however even if we have
uh the term limits what you just said
was then everybody would just do the
right thing
i would actually argue forgive the
skeptic in me but i think it's a healthy
skeptic that a lot of those guys are
saying
well i'm only going to be here for six
years eight years but then i'm going to
try to get a job
lobbying working for the people who
really make all these machines run
so i'm still going to vote a certain way
so that they will like me and hire me at
the end of the day well
i have the math for you marianne okay 42
of former legislators become lobbyists
and an additional 25 percent work for a
company
that includes lobbying and that's my
point that's my point so let's not leave
that out of our calculation
of what would occur if magically because
there were
term limits uh we're to assume they're
going to do the right thing
so let's supplement term limits and say
guess what
uh you have a 10-year ban on going to
a lobbyist exactly or a major firm
that exactly included these activities
that you touched as a legislator
and one of the one of the things i would
throw in there too particularly if you
were to have term limits
and let's say a bar on a certain
activities post office
we'll give you a raise it's like tell
you what you do this thing for x years
we'll pay you even better i mean they're
paid fine now but they could like in my
mind it would be a very
small price to pay if you felt confident
that they were going to look out for the
public interest i agree
with that them and teachers yeah
teachers need a raise too
for sure um so these are some of the
structural things that
i'm going to be trying trying to drive
um in the days to come and i love any
member of congress who's for term limits
because then you could tell that they're
uh you know that they're truthful um and
it's treating a symptom though it's
treating a symptom and sometimes you
need to treat the symptom but we're
still going to have to get down to the
deeper cause
because we have to talk about all of the
ways
uh in which the system mitigates against
people doing the right thing
oh yeah it's it's unfortunately it's
like a layer cake
where i'd say term limits might be third
or fourth on my list like public
financing of
elections gerrymandering
money in politics is the issue that's
the cancer underlying all the other
cancers
i mean tell me the numbers again
marianne well we're
looking into this stuff well successful
congressional candidate
uh raises 1.6 million and then for
senate it's over 10 million
so given the current makeup of the
supreme court
it's not reasonable to assume we're
going to be able to overturn citizens
united anytime soon
so we're going to have to go the
direction of an effort at a
constitutional amendment to establish
public funding for federal campaigns
because as long as the money floods the
system the way it does and then you have
an addition to that that the political
parties themselves
flood the system to keep out in the case
of the democrats the more progressive
candidates the more progressive
candidates are the ones who are actually
expressing the will of the people rather
than the will of corporate interests
we have to have some more radical
truth-telling here we've got to just say
this stuff as sick as it is
because you heal in life through a kind
of detox process
yeah it stuff has to come up we've got
to start naming it
you know i look at the american
political system and it's almost like
we're a family a big family where both
parents are alcoholic
and the kids who are the citizens can
tell mommy and daddy aren't really
telling the truth here we're not having
the conversation about what's really
true
and you and i both know that
offstage a lot of them will have
a more truthful conversation but that
doesn't make me feel better
well well this is the danger uh to me
marianne is that
it almost doesn't matter who you get in
there if the machine is this broken
it's like like we can say to ourselves
look if we just had like a different
candidate in there
uh like we need to fundamentally change
the incentives of the
folks in power if we're going to see
some of the
massive changes that we need uh and
right now you get to dc
and the best people i know who are in dc
are incredibly frustrated they feel
stuck like flies in amber you know they
like fought through fire
to go to dc to try and make a positive
impact and they get jaded
and cynical pretty quick uh or
over a long period of time either way
like that that town
uh that town does need like a
massive operating system
upgrade or culture shift i don't
you're letting people off the hook that
i don't let off the hook
tell the truth you you will prob not
only
will you probably lose your seat for
doing it you
you probably will lose your seat you
know it's not just that you might you
probably will
beco not just because the voters will
turn on you but because the party
establishment will turn on you
lose it anyway i know that as a as a as
a
candidate i said things that man lady
you're getting off the stage you're not
going to be on the stage next time but
you know what andrew
maybe i'm i was not they were able to
cut me off at the knees in terms of
funding and
so forth maybe they didn't want me a
little party online at the democratic
convention but you know what
i'm still saying it and in america today
you still say it so
so lose the election damn it lose it if
it means you lose the election
and i i honestly think you know there's
something about
being my age you know
i'm old enough to remember earlier today
i had the honor of talking to bernice
king
and who's martin luther king's daughter
and
i have written quite a bit about her
father about martin luther king and
gandhi etc
and i'm old enough to remember i was a
little girl but i do remember the
assassinations of bobby kennedy and
martin luther king
and a lot of people younger than my
generation
don't necessarily realize the
psychological
effect the chilling effect that it had
on us
that people such as martin such as bobby
who were speaking
truth juice the real thing
you talk about the soul of america they
were literally shot and killed in front
of our eyes
and there was a very loud unspoken
message in those assassinations
and those bullets psychically shot all
of us and just in case we hadn't gotten
the message they shot students at kent
state to make sure we got the message
and the message was go home there will
be no further protest
do whatever you want in the private
sector
but leave the public sector alone to
whomever it is
once it's so bad it's willing to to kill
in order to control it
and that's what my generation did in
large part
and we kidded ourselves that we still
had a lot of choices because we could
buy the blue one we could buy the red
one we could buy the yellow one
and it's only been in the last few years
that we realize in the marketplace
where this country so prides itself on
on
on variety and choice you can have this
kind of computer or that kind of
computer you can have this kind of
refrigerator or that kind of
refrigerator
but you have to have a narrowly
prescribed political conversation
but you know what has happened to people
who are my age
the idea that as my father would say the
bastards got to you
the idea that we might not die
knowing on the day we die that we didn't
really do what we came here to do
is actually scarier to us than the
thought that they might kill us if we do
to be a radical truth-teller in america
today is to take a risk
and my message is take it anyway
that's a beautiful message and i think
one that's very
uh right for this time for this time in
american history
you've seen them they've made you think
about
whether or not you should get them and
those
are the earbuds that are sticking out of
everyone's ears and you're like do i
need to get them
and do i want to do the same thing
everyone else has done in terms of
getting
the particular earbuds that look that
way well we've got a choice for you
that is efficient exciting
innovative it's the raycon everyday e25
earbuds they're best ones yet with six
hours of play time
more bass i'm not really much of an
audiophile but the things
sound great they actually make your
music sound better
than really anything else i've used and
i barely noticed that [ __ ]
so if you're in the market for ear buds
and you want something a bit different
that says something about you
can get fifteen percent off your order
at buy ratecon dot com slash yang that's
by recon dot com slash yang for a
special 15 percent discount on raycon
wireless earbuds
check it out now by raycon.com yang
they're black they're cool they're like
little obsidian
earbuds you stick in your ears and they
work great
and you can get them at half the price
of the other guys you know who i'm
talking about
there's a 45-day return policy so if you
don't like them you just return them
no questions asked but talk about
efficient i mean
half the price uh is is hard to argue
with
plus i hate to say it but you lose these
things
and snoop dogg wears them snoop dogg
endorses two things corona
the beer not the virus which i love and
raycon earbuds
so you know they're legit
[Music]
so you spoke at um the people's party
there was a um it was like i believe it
was mostly virtual
uh some of my favorite people spoke i
mean uh
addition to you um cornell west who i
admire a great deal scott stanton's from
um my campaign yeah he was great nina
turner and on and on oh i'm so glad you
saw him and that i got a huge yeah
i thought it was wonderful yeah it
seemed wonderful
um i was a little envious people who
uh attribute universal basic income to
me i say talk to scott
scott is actually the progenitor of a
lot more of the
uh finding research um well like i said
um milton friedman even richard nixon
discussed it to some extent
i mean it's a very very old idea yeah
all the way back
but you have popularized it for our time
and you deserve credit for that
oh well thank you uh i you know i mean
had a lot of help
uh so the message i got
um from the people's party convention
was
uh look like and you said it earlier in
this conversation it's like look i want
uh joe and carmel to win i want trump to
get out because
if trump's the president like we can't
get much of anything done
but then the message is for democrats
hey
um start actually enacting these changes
that the people care about
or uh we need a new party we're coming
uh to challenge you that was the the
message i got was that
correct did i get the right message i
suppose
i think a lot of progressives myself
included
feel politically homeless these days
um after what happened in the last two
presidential campaigns after seeing what
happens in so many of the
congressional campaigns and the ways
that you and i have spoken when i was
growing up
the serious liberal at that time we
would have called the serious liberal
which is today's progressive
had a home in the democratic party and
there's been almost a purging
so i'm a lifelong democrat i grew up as
a democrat
my father every other word out of his
mouth in any political conversation was
fdr it makes me very sad
because i think that the democratic
party like the republican party has lost
its soul to some extent
and both parties need to reclaim their
soul but i think it's going to be up to
the democrats hopefully biden will win
and then it's going to be up to him
although judging how he's treating this
campaign
i don't know why are progressives
treated like
practically like pariahs and so there
are a lot of people particularly young
people who don't have the institutional
memory that someone like i have
i remember a time when the democratic
party was the go-to place
if you really were making humanitarian
concern
for the people your bottom line
i remember a time like that many of
these kids don't even remember that
and so you know i have two minds about
this on
one hand if you look at our history the
abolitionist party came from the
uh abolitionist party i mean the
abolitionist movement came from the
abolitionist party
the women's suffrage movement came from
the women's party
social security came from the socialist
party so third-party voices have been
very
important uh in american history but on
the other hand we all know the political
realities that exist here
um my personal choice will be that the
democratic party sort of comes to its
senses
and and allows the wider tent uh
philosophically that they
claim to be so proud of ethnically and
if that's the case
um it certainly would be the place where
i'd like to
put my head on the pillow but i'm going
to go my principles are more important
to me than a party
and i know what i will be doing is going
wherever those principles are
given the respect that they deserve and
the political
power that they deserve my first choice
during my run was for the democratic
party to
embrace a bolder set of policies and
solutions and proposals than
they seem to have and universal basic
income was obviously the one that
uh that i made the center of my campaign
but i'm with you that our political
system right now
is a duopoly that is not serving a lot
of people well
in like a whole uh in a variety of ways
and that we all wish at least i
certainly wish that we had a more
dynamic political system that enable
different points of view
and because i'm the
the structured thinker that i am to me
the big change we can make that would
help is ranked choice voting
yes right choice voting would very much
help also you know you say
duopoly and duopoly is the word that
people use because they're two major
parties
but i think in terms of the pattern that
it represents
we need to recognize that the duopoly is
a monopoly
and it's a monopolistic reality this
country this is why we have anti-trust
laws although
we hardly we hardly uh prosecute them
even in like in the business world yeah
much less the political so it's a
suppression of different voices
but i agree with you on the steps to get
there um
uh uh ranked choice voting would be a
very good idea
oh because even now if you look at the
message that you know
you know for a lot of folks during
this run up to november is they they say
look i'm going to vote for joe and
kamala but you know joe wouldn't have
been my
first choice and so if you had a more
dynamic way of expressing your
preference
then there's no more berating people for
quote unquote wasting your vote it's
like you and i would have done
very very well with ranked choice voting
i like to think so marianne but but but
you know this
this narrative around uh wasting your
vote is
uh really destructive it's really
corrosive it's you know like it like let
voters just figure out who the heck they
like
uh who expresses their point of view the
best their values their policies is the
best
and then because right now unfortunately
a lot of us now have become
um almost like investors in different
ways where
i remember when they started telling us
like which movies do well it's like like
everything is all about like oh i want
to
pick the winning whatever the heck it is
and like not waste my preference in this
case
you know the vote on someone who's like
quote unquote not going to win
that's all part of the manipulation
another aspect of that was remember the
canard during the campaign
that the dnc had to quote unquote narrow
the field
no they didn't that's what the primary
voters are for
so all of that ridiculous react tv
reality show with the
uh debates etc where everybody is given
two seconds or whatever
plus you and i and others got far less
than everybody else god who are members
of the club at the time
so um all of that these thoughts put out
there like we have to narrow the field
you have to go with the one who can beat
trump and
i mean really i i said so often on the
campaign
that we were living at a moment where
what seems like the safe choice is
probably the most dangerous thing you
can do
because trump is not a politician he's a
phenomenon
and in too many ways the democratic
party is stuck in thinking of the
of the 20th century this is the 21st
century it's asymmetrical
um but i don't want to go too much into
that because right now we just want joe
to win
so there's that fine line where don't go
too far
no i i mean i remember talking to you
about that on the trail
um and you and i agreed that like like
the goal was
in many ways to start a contrary
phenomenon like opposite trump
uh you know like that like that that was
a vision
um certainly like i agreed with you you
know
like when when i i was deciding to run i
thought you know what
we need is like we need like a different
approach um because the machinery is
failing in so many ways and so if you
have someone
who uh reminds people of this
um family set of institutions like that
that might not be the
the winning bet um though like you
100 joe and kamal let's go and you know
win this thing
um but certainly when i was trying to
figure out how to defeat
trump um circa 2017 2018 it's one reason
i ran i was like well you know i think
we need a different
uh type of approach to politics so you
and i saw eye to eye on that i mean it's
one reason we both
ran absolutely
well you've started an important
conversation for all of us marianne
you've been such a force for
uh goodness and progress and
enlightenment
uh i've i've learned so much from you i
felt like you were a fellow traveler
and when we met um
you were so generous in spirit
uh you know where you saw me
as someone who was running for the same
reasons you were running like we were
just
going to try and do what we could for uh
this country and this society
um and so i've i've always been grateful
to you frankly like you were one of the
first people
that uh i considered a friend
in this race uh and i feel honored to be
your friend if there's anything
that we can do together to help move
this country in the right direction
i'm all for it i think that you and i
may have different approaches to some of
these things but i think both
of us know that uh we would make very
very similar choices in the vast
majority of
[Laughter]
yeah of of uh settings in terms of
policy values like trying to just
improve the lives of the american people
uh and we need you really badly like i
love your voice i love your
uh vision and values and a lot of
americans loved your vision and values
and i saw it
you know it's like like there's all the
[ __ ] and then there's like when
you're just like
out there with everyday americans that
they knew
like you know that they uh saw in you
the person that you actually are uh and
you know um being a part of that was was
like uh
the honor of a lifetime for me really
like and
considering someone like you like a
comrade in arms
um like really elevated my sense of what
was possible
well thank you and i feel the same way
about you andrew
and uh the march of truth
to the best of our ability to discern it
and to
articulate it is bigger than any one
campaign
um and we're both still out there and i
feel the same way about you
let's do whatever we can hopefully we
did it with this podcast
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode